greil marcus ist einer der bedeutendsten
amerikanischen kulturtheoretiker seit
dem turbulenten sixties erforscht hat
den einfluss von rock pop und punk auf
die gesellschaft neben vielem anderen
ist der kultur kultautor auch ein großer
bob dylan gibt
[Musik]
d
herr marx ist herzlich willkommen
bob dylan 1965 das rolling stone
magazine hat like a rolling stone zu
einem zum wichtigsten rocksong der
geschichte gekrönt kennen sie diesen
song überhaupt noch hören
immer wenn ich diesen song hörer
begeistert ihr mich und macht mich
glücklich und ich höre ihn jedes mal ein
wenig anders jedes mal gerade eben habe
ich zugehört wie mike bloomfield gitarre
und bob dylans rhythmusgitarre
aufeinandertreffen auf einen schlag und
dröhnend so dass sie jeden satz der aus
dylans mund kommt auf unbestimmt betonen
das ist einfach wunderbar zu hören wir
eigentlich mitten drin in dem was die
faszination für sie von der musik
ausmacht aber auch das was sie bedeuten
als autor als kritiker für die musik das
nämlich diese art von ministerium etwas
zum ersten mal zu hören und immer wieder
zum ersten mal zu hören
auch als ihnen eine art von kult figur
gemacht hat in der vergangenheit das
kann ich nicht unterstützen
ich sehe mich selber überhaupt nicht so
aber ich weiß dass wenn man sich einem
musikstück annähern will
oder einem gemälde einen roman oder auch
einem politischen ereignis wenn sie von
vornherein schon wissen was sie darüber
denken um was es geht warum es
entstanden ist weshalb sprechen wir dann
darüber
für mich ist das totale
zeitverschwendung es gibt keinen grund
das zu tun
ohne die fähigkeit sich überraschen zu
lassen die eigenen vermutungen durch das
erleben in frage zu stellen warum
verschwinden sie dann andere leute zeit
ich weiß für mich ist einer der
schlüsselmomente anfang der 90er jahre
als ich ihr buch lipstick traces zu den
ersten mal in die hände bekommen habe
und gemerkt habe da denkt das schreibt
jemand etwas auf eine geheime geschichte
der kultur des 20 jahrhunderts von data
bis punk und er schreibt etwas was ich
noch nie gelesen habe und ist dieses
lipstick traces ein produkt das sie eben
auch bei surprise quasi geschrieben
haben sich am anfang wollte ich ein buch
über punk schreiben
ich war es einfach leid bloß
journalistisch zu schreiben und hatte
das bedürfnis ein buch zu schreiben über
irgendetwas ich begann damit dass sich
in dingen herum stöberte die andere
leute gesagt in zusammenhängen die
andere leute aufgezeigt hatten
aber ich habe nichts daraus gemacht es
gab keine geschichte kein herz keine
leidenschaft so führte das eine zum
anderen und nach einem jahr oder so war
ich mittendrin
ich befand mich in einem unbekannten
land für das sich die karten selber
zeichnen musste was war das programm was
wollten sie mit diesem buch erzählen
diese geschichte die eigentlich im
mittelalter bei den kritikern beginnt
über die geschichte der orange ist die
geschichte der dadaisten die geschichte
des punks des rocks alles in einer
vermenge lagerung drin eine wirklich für
geheime verknüpfung vollzieht
es ist sehr einfach den fall einer art
von hüpfspiel einfluss zu konstruieren
diese leute hier beeinflussen leute da
und diese beeinflussen leute dort und
das ergibt etwas das ist aber eine
reduktionistischen fast anatomisch
medizinischer art dinge zu betrachten
was man dabei nicht sie sind für mich
war genau das die geschichte dass sich
während des ganzen zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts hindurch gewisse stimmen
erheben
es ist eine art schrei ein schrei der
freude des entzückens der verzweiflung
von hass und missfallen dieser schrei
sucht nach einer sprache wie kann ich
rüberbringen was ich zu sagen habe und
dann verklingt dieser schrei und die
menschen die geschrien haben
verschwinden
sie verlassen die geschichte dann eine
generation später kommt dieser gleiche
geist der gleiche schrei von neuem und
verklingt wieder das geschieht laufend
menschen entdecken immer wieder die
gleiche sprache des nein sagen diese
geschichte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
unterscheidet sich von der geschichte
der kriege die revolutionen des
fortschritts der technologischen
innovationen
das ist eine andere art von geschichte
ich nannte das buch lipstick traces weil
es von bewegungen und kulturen handelt
die kaum eine spur hinterlassen haben
und doch sind sie zauberhaft sie haben
eine besondere faszination und eine
großartige buntheit es ist interessant
wenn sie eben diese gegen geschichte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts erzählen es
gibt natürlich menschen die weniger
euphorisiert sind über diesen
underground über diese gegenkultur die
einen verlust auch der hohen klassischen
kultur unserer europäischen kultur
[Musik]
an diesem verlust auch leiten ich hatte
vor ein paar jahren george steiner bei
mir zu gast und steiner hat erzählt wer
big sind am ende dieses langen
kulturellen europäischen nachmittags wir
können nur noch einen epilog auf diese
kultur schreiben und ist voller
melancholie können sie diese melancholie
verstehen ja sicher aber was george
steiner wirklich beklagt und ich glaube
nicht dass das eine geheime absicht ist
was er bedauert ist der niedergang oder
das verschwinden der traditionellen
klassen struktur eigentlich die
mittelalterliche klassen struktur die es
ermöglicht gewisse formen von kultur nur
für auserwählte leute zu schaffen und
anderen vorzuenthalten sodass es
voneinander getrennte kulturen gibt im
sinn von wir wollen nicht dass dieser
typ in seinen beinkleidern das opernhaus
betritt wir wollen ihn dort nicht einmal
als zuschauer ganz zu schweigen dass sie
auf der bühne steht und seinen sohn
griff darum geht es beim kulturellen
klassen system dessen verschwinden wir
beobachten aber auch immer sie diese
mittelalterliche religiös geprägte
gesellschaft seiner bedauert dass das
wir an einer einem manko an
metaphysischen 20 stellen ideen
vorstellungen und ein lebensverhältnisse
leiden ist denn die ganze gegenkultur
eine kalte strategische harte coole
bewegung
das argument die beteiligung der
menschen am kulturellen gespräch führe
dazu dass die kultur nach unten
nivelliert werde und dass die großen
fragen sind wir warum gibt es uns
weshalb gibt dass sprache was kann sie
ausdrücken
ganz zu schweigen von den spirituellen
fragen was gott von uns will auf die
argumentation dass diese fragen
verschwinden gibt es zwei antworten
die eine ist dass diese fragen durchaus
verschwinden
und in anderer form wieder auftauchen
können und die andere antwort lautet
diese fragen verschwinden nicht jedes
große kunstwerk wie like a rolling stone
dass wir gerade gehört haben stellt
diese fragen wie fühlt es sich an was
bedeutet es auf diesem planeten zu leben
jetzt und gerade hier warum gibt es dich
größere fragen kann man sich gar nicht
stellen
was mich sehr erstaunt wenn man ihre
texte liest ihre kurzen geschichten ihre
bücher man hat immer das gefühl sie
seien da wo es brennt darüber etwas
passiert wie ein zeuge der durch durch
zeit und raum geht und immer dieses
dieses magische moment und deswegen habe
ich die frage gestellt nach der 20 cents
oder nach dem materiellen dass sie da
sind wo etwas magisches passiert auch
wenn sie über eine geschichte schreiben
die in den zwanziger jahren oder oder
vor 100 jahren oder vor 500 jahren
passiert ist das ist keine strategie
kein lehrsatz ich bin einfach voller
enthusiasmus wenn ich über etwas
schreiben
ich will wissen wie es dort war ich will
wissen wie sich die leute gefühlt haben
aber es ist nicht gesagt dass man sie
danach fragen kann und sogar wenn man es
kann
erzählen sie einem nicht unbedingt die
wahrheit deshalb ist es naheliegend dass
ich mich in die lage andere leute
versetzte soweit ich das kann was würden
sie sagen was würden sie wirklich denken
was würde ich sagen was würde ich denken
wenn ich gerade jetzt in dieser
situation wäre
oder wie kann ich diese situation
vorantreiben
es gibt eine stelle in lipstick traces
mit meinem bevorzugten atheisten dem
cabaret voltaire veteranen richard
hülsenbeck erhält in danzig eine
vorlesung 1920 und ich lasse ihn all
diese bizarren handlungen vollbringen
theatralische handlungen die darin
gipfeln dass er auf eine blut- kapsel
beißt und blut aus seinem mund schießt
und über das hemd hinunter läuft während
er weiterspricht so etwas ist nie
geschehen
trotzdem setze ich diese szene dort ein
um den moment zu dramatisieren
einige seiten weiter komme ich darauf
zurück und sage dass es zwar nie so
stattgefunden habe
dass er aber die haarsträubenden dinge
die ich ihm sagen lasse tatsächlich
gesagt hat da wird auf theatralische
mittel zurückgegriffen
sie können sich beim schreiben von
geschichte vollumfänglich an die fakten
treue halten
in diesem buch und ich hoffe auch in
anderen büchern die ich geschrieben habe
sind alle fakten korrekt die daten
stimmen die orte stimmen die
übersetzungen sind korrekt und so weiter
wenn sie das einmal haben sagen sie sich
hier ist was war was aber hätten die
leute gewollt was wäre geschehen wenn
man die situation etwas weiter voran
getrieben hätte damit erreichen sie das
innere der menschen über die sie
schreiben ihre wünsche die ängste das
zögern ihren mut also universelle
kategorien die zeit unabhängig sind und
man hat ein bisschen das gefühl dass wie
zwischen der wissenschaft oder der der
physik und metaphysik liegt eine zone
der spekulation die sie emotional
ausfüllen in dem sie ihre begeisterung
zum ausdruck bringen
und jetzt aber auch aufgefallen ich habe
einer ihrer texte als amerikanisches
hörbuch gehört und diese sprache
plötzlich beim zuhören merkt man dass
sie eine ganz einfache eine analytische
eine sehr strukturierte kurze sprache
verwenden die so zeitlos scheint ich
weiß nicht wie kann ich diese frage
beantworten er zur beikost vielleicht
eigentlich kann ich einen anderen dreh
machen weil sie beschreiben die sprache
von bob dylan einmal als eine alte
sprache ist eine sprache die wir als
jahrhunderten der sprache schöpft
sprache ist etwas lebendiges eine
sprache wird laufend getestet richard
hülsenbeck sagte unter anderem unsere
kritik die kritik der dabei ist im
modernen leben begann so wie jede kritik
beginnt mit unser zweifel wurde so groß
dass wir uns fragten ob strache einen
derart großen zweifel ausdrücken kann
zweifel an die legitimation von
autorität wert der gesellschaft am
nutzen von sprache und deshalb sagt er
mussten wir die konventionelle sprachen
verlassen und anfangen uns in geräusch
poesie auszudrücken
die aus wörtern geformt wurde ohne
grammatikalische struktur um zu
versuchen und zu zeigen dass sprache die
moderne nicht erfassen kann
denken wir an die entdeckung der tour
des camps der vernichtungslager in
deutschland und polen und weiter im
osten nach dem ende des zweiten
weltkriegs sprache konnte damals nicht
ausdrücken nicht einmal beschreiben was
wir sahen als wir diese filme oder fotos
anschauen und sie kann es bis heute
nicht
und so bringen die menschen noch immer
damit und man bleibt einfach weiter dran
ich glaube was da die legistische
internationale die später zur situation
ist ischen internationalen wurde und
punk verbindet ist diese obsession
bezüglich die grenzen von strache die
freie rede ist etwas komplizierter
es geht nicht bloß darum das zu sagen
was man sagen will
es bedeutet auch dass man während des
sprechens herausfindet was man sagen
will und ob man sich entsprechend
ausdrücken
ob man es so sagen kann dass andere
menschen darauf reagieren und sie zu
sich selber sagen können genauso habe
ich es gemeint das ist schwierig sie
haben punk erwähnt sie haben die suche
nach dem nach der soll ich sagen
dem ausbruch aus der sprache erwähnt und
es gibt ein kleines schönes beispiel aus
einem interview mit ihnen wo sie gefragt
werden ob punk die eigentliche apotheose
der dadaistischen musik ist und dieses
kleine beispiel wollen wir uns anhören
es stammt aus einem online projekt an
dem sie teilgenommen haben
da daten über 100 jährigen jubiläum von
data dass jetzt das schweizer fernsehen
mitproduziert hat und jetzt den grimme
online preis gewonnen habt nicht zuletzt
wegen ihnen und wir schauen uns den
kulturkritiker grand marquis schnell auf
dem bildschirm an
[Musik]
erzählt wie reagieren sie auf sich
selbst wenn sich sehen wissen sie ich
weiß nicht ob ich glaube was sie soeben
gesagt habe ich könne nicht glauben dass
richard bösebeck bank nicht gemacht
hätte jetzt denke ich vielleicht hätte
er in der zwischenzeit wenn ich das
jetzt sehe weiß ich keine antworten auf
diese fragen
gewisse dinge erscheinen mir in einem
moment als richtig und in einem anderen
als falsch wir sind im bereich der
spekulation
wir können nicht zurück und richard
hülsen weg fragen ob er hätte er zwei
jahre länger gelebt er starb 1974 ob er
wenn er lange genug gelebt hätte um an
orgien der uk zu hören gesagt hätte
natürlich natürlich warum hat es so
lange gedauert bis das jemand sagt es so
sagt oder er hätte gesagt das ist bloss
lärm warum sollte ich da zu hören
dann würden sie sagen rösenbeck 1918 und
1920 sprachen sie über buddhismus sie
sprachen über den wert von lärm und das
lärm musik übertrifft ist das hier nicht
wovon sie gesprochen hatten und ich
könnte sagen nein das ist überhaupt
nicht was ich meinte oder er könnte
sagen wissen sie was sie haben recht
spielen sie es nochmal ich glaube dass
ist genau auch etwas was es zur spannung
macht wenn man wenn man ihre analysen
hört oder liest das eben sie mit diesem
material spielen können eine art medium
sind zwischen sound zwischen technischen
dingen die intelligenz sehens dinge die
man nur mit dem herz eher spüren kann
mit neugierde begegnen kann
und dazu habe ich etwas was mich
irritiert hat sehr scans nur einer der
großen französischen chansonniers und
einer dieser vielleicht auch leitfiguren
eine art europäischen soll ich fast
schon sagen gegenkultur oder oder
dissidenz gegen ein system
er hat in einem wichtigen französischen
interview in den frühen 80er jahren
einmal ein ganz vehement statement
abgegeben
dass seine kunst geben oder seine lieder
seine chansons keine kunst sein weil sie
keine vermittlung bräuchten weil sie
populär seien und dass erst dann etwas
kunst ist wenn jemand kommen muss und
das erklären muss und das hat er für
einen großen unterschied gehalten also
sind sie mit der standspur ein nein ich
halte das für unsinn
aber ich finde auch sie sollten das was
ganz pur sagt nicht unbedingt ernst
nehmen
im ernst künstler lügen immer er könnte
an diesem tag in einer sehr schlechten
stimmung gewesen sein und gesagt haben
alles was ich tue ist wertlos
und vielleicht war das auch sein gefühl
er könnte auch mit dem interviewer
gespielt und dienen dazu gedrängt haben
zu sagen ja sie haben recht
ihre arbeit ist bloße zeitverschwendung
einfach nur unterhaltung sie hat keinen
wirklichen inhalt des kerns pur wusste
sehr genau dass seine tradition des
chansons die tradition des troubadours
der sich über die gesellschaft äußert
dass diese tradition jahrhunderte
zurückreicht bis zu den ursprünglichen
troubadours diese waren durchaus
volkstümliche künstler aber sie sangen
verschlüsselt sie sangen für eine elite
und sie überbrachten botschaften die
eigentlich verboten waren
die romantische liebe war für die kirche
etwas sehr gefährliches darüber haben
sie gesungen und sie sangen über die
liebe zwischen bürgerlichen und adligen
das ist ein großes thema der troubadour
lieder strengstens verboten sehr sehr
gefährlich ganz wohl war in dieser
tradition
das wusste er aber die vorstellung dass
etwas erst kunst ist wenn es erklärt
werden muss
ich würde es umgekehrt sehen etwas ist
kunst wenn man es nicht erklären muss
wenn es dem erklärer entwischt
ungeachtet wie gelehrt wie aufmerksam
wie aufrichtig ein kommentator eine
kritik sein mag wenn er oder sie etwas
kommentiert
wissen sowohl der zuschauer der zuhörer
wie auch der sprecher dass das bloß eine
kleine skizze dessen sein kann was es
wirklich ist
ich möchte eine kleine orange
zwischenschalten und auf ihre
vermittlung in anspruch nehmen für ein
kleines video das wir uns jetzt
anschauen werden
[Musik]
wir brauchen dich nicht
die kleinen sportler
[Musik]
was haben wir hier gesehen
wir sahen gerade kleenex liliput zürichs
wundervolle punk band 1978 gegründet es
gab sie bis 1983 mit verschiedenen lied
sängerinnen eine band in die ich mich
beim ersten hören sofort verliebt haben
sich befreundete mich mit marina der
gitarristin die dieses jahr vor wenigen
monaten 61 jährige an krebs starb
ein echter verlust am bass die
kurzhaarige blonde claudia schiffer die
malerin
sie war damals malerin und ist es bis
heute lieselotte h die schlagzeugerin
und regula singen die sängerin ich
mochte diese band von anfang an
ich habe nie etwas ähnliches gehört wie
das was sie machten
und ich glaube auch niemand anderes
wer zuvor hätte musik kreiert basierend
auf kleinen mädchen die zuckend auf
einem spielplatz herumrennen und lustige
geräusche machen während sie einander
jagen und niederschlagen wieder
aufstehen und wegrennen
von da kommt ihre musik aus diesem
gefühl von mädchen die umher rennen und
sich nicht darum kümmern was
irgendjemand darüber denkt in einem
freien raum dem freiraum eines
spielplatzes
sie rennen nicht über möbel stolpern
durch haus und sie stehen nicht auf und
rennen durch die klassenzimmer in der
schule wo sie beschimpft werden nein
auf einem spielplatz wo alles möglich
ist die idee ok daraus machen wir musik
weil das der sound von freien frauen ist
eine weibliche freie rede
das ist mein kommentar ist es das was
das entzücken die freude dass echte
novum ihrer musik ausmacht was aus
diesem video nicht wirklich hervorgeht
da sind sie irgendwie nervös
bei ihren platten aufnahmen sind sie
jedes mal etwas weitergegangen jedesmal
und wurden je länger desto freier mann
hörte in ihrer musik ab 1978 während wir
folgenden fünf jahre menschen die immer
freie wurden und dabei entdeckten dass
die welt komplexer gefährlicher und
angst einflößender ist als ihr sich
anfänglich vielleicht vorgestellt hatten
aber sie waren bereit das zu ertragen
der darüber zu sprechen es zu
denunzieren auszubrechen
diese dieser ausschnitt ist als einer
vorabend informationszentrum gewesen
also die man sich um 18 uhr anschauen
bevor wirklich eigentlich das
abendprogramm beginnt und man hat schon
ein bisschen dass gefühle sei für alle
ein bisschen eine überforderung profil
gewesen für die ganze band und ich
glaube auch irgendwas machen wir hier ja
ich glaube das stimmt weil es nicht ihr
normaler rahmen ist die art kleiner
clubs in denen sie üblicherweise
spielten oder vielleicht auf der straße
hinten auf einem lastwagen oder so etwas
nicht sagte sie wirken etwas nervös und
sie versuchen alles präzise klingen zu
lassen
etwas was vielleicht an den anfang
unseres gesprächs noch einmal anschließt
mit dieser frage nach dem mysterium die
frage nach dem richtigen moment da zu
sein wo etwas passiert diese
leidenschaft zu spüren sie auch zu
suchen
also es gibt eine große kette von
momenten historisch an denen sie
teilgenommen haben sie waren mit 16 an
dem tag in berlin als man die maler hat
begonnen aufzubauen
sie waren in woodstock sie waren in
berkeley als
die 64 die free speech bewegung aufkam
sie scheinen immer da zu sein sie und
präsent zu sein aber da ist das auch ein
bisschen die frage des vermittlers noch
einmal dass sie vielleicht kann ich zum
beispiel im robert frank der berühmte
schweizer fotograf der die beat
generation fotografiert hat mit den
beatniks unterwegs war und immer sagt
aber ich bin kein beatnik ich habe sie
nur fotografiert ist das ähnlich bei
ihnen sind sie ein rock'n'roller sind
sie ein punk oder sind sie nur der der
da ist und es und ist überholt zu uns
holen
ich bin ein trittbrettfahrer ich bin
california
ich stamme aus einer netten mitte glas
vorstadt familie und ich halte meine
augen und ohren offen
ich erinnere mich an meine zeit in
berkeley während des free speech
movement es war turbulent
es war verwirrend es war voller
täglicher widersprüche auf welcher seite
bin ich was denke ich über die rede die
jeden gehört haben und weshalb bin ich
hier
wann wird dass sie aufhören wir sprechen
hier von einem dreimonatigen protest der
den campus in jeder denkbaren art und
weise auf den kopf stellte und die leute
stritten die ganze zeit darüber
anscheinen sprachen sie über nichts
anderes und ich erinnere mich wie ich 19
jahre alt über den campus der university
of california ging und dachte was habe
ich für ein glück genau jetzt hier zu
sein weil er geschichte gemacht wird
dass sie es nicht dass diese ereignisse
unbedingt in die geschichtsbücher
eingehen und dass leute wie sie und ich
so viele jahre später darüber
diskutieren würden ohne frage was damals
geschah veränderte die menschen die dort
und dabei waren
es war ihre eigene geschichte die sie
machten
die menschen prägten ihre eigene
geschichte das ist was ich damals dachte
und was ich seid ihr immer gedacht habe
geschichte besteht nicht aus
entscheidungen die hoch oben gefällt
werden und all den menschen die dafür
bezahlen müssen
die in kriegen und abenteuern dieser art
ihr leben dafür geben
geschichte ist das handeln der menschen
mit dem sie ihr eigenes leben und das
ihres umfelds drängen geschichte ist die
art wie sie etwas erleben dass sie für
immer mit einem gefühl des staunens
zurücklässt
mit einem gefühl von unsicherheit in dem
ihre identität nicht festgelegt ist wo
ihr gefühl für zeit und ereignis labil
ist wo sie nicht zufrieden sind weil sie
etwas erlebt haben das so mächtig war
das so sehr eine verwirklichung des
lebens in seinen besten facetten war
dass sie etwas vermissen wenn es
entschwindet und sie werden immer danach
suchen auf die eine oder andere art
genau das passierte den dadaisten das
war ihr leben menschen die für ein paar
monate in zürich in einem kabarett herum
tänzeln
dann ist es vorbei und sie gehen zurück
in ihrer normalen beruflichen
beschäftigungen
ich bin ein bildhauer ich bin ein maler
ich ein dichter ich bin arzt ich ein
psychoanalytiker und den ganzen rest
ihres lebens oder ball hülsenbeck janko
oder zara sagten sie dass es passiert
was geschah in dieser bar was machen wir
eigentlich warum komme ich nicht darüber
hinweg bösen weg sagt er am ende seines
lebens als arzt war ich ein erfolg aber
als dabei ist der sache die mir am
meisten am herzen lag war ich ein
misserfolg das sagte er in seinen 70 da
sagte er immer noch ich habe das
versprechen dass ich im cabaret voltaire
gemacht hatten
eingelöst was war das versprechen ich
habe es nie genau gewusst aber ich weiß
dass ich mir selber etwas versprochen
habe und ich hatte mir selber
versprochen die welt zu verändern
diese welt verändern natürlich eben
zuerst einmal wie bei rilke in seinem
gedicht du musst dein leben ändern und
es gibt momente in denen man wie einen
impuls bekommt und dieser impuls ist
manchmal eben so gehen manchmal exogen
und sind ein zu einem impuls kann ein
lied sein kann ein text sein kann eine
performance sein aber es braucht auch
eine eine innere bereitschaft dazu
wirklich wie am roulette tisch in einem
casino alles auf etwas zu setzen und
sagen das ist es und wenn ich sie höre
wie sie erzählen von der geschichte der
bedeutung der geschichte den ungewissen
von geschichten dem zufallsprinzip der
geschichte dass etwas so geht oder so
geht dann ist stellt sich mir ein
bisschen auch eine persönliche frage an
sie ihr leben hat er mit einer großen
ungewissheit eigentlich begonnen mit
einem mysterium begonnen jetzt jahr für
ihren vater verloren bevor sie auf die
welt gekommen sind ja da möchte ich auf
verschiedene punkte antworten
es stimmt mein vater wurde im zweiten
weltkrieg getötet sechs monate bevor ich
zur welt kam
ich wuchs auf ohne wirklich etwas über
ihn zu wissen
ich kannte keine details über seinen tod
im haus wo ich aufwuchs gab es keine
bilder von ihm
wenn ich meine verwandten seinen bruder
seine schwester und seinen vater in
philadelphia woher er stammte besuchte
ich lebte in kalifornien
dort gab es bilder aber man sprach nicht
darüber
es war kein geheimnis sondern einfach
schweigen was in mir ein gefühl des
nichtwissens erzeugte über die
wichtigsten dinge
ich war 56 10 jahre alt ein gefühl dinge
nicht zu wissen die klar und
selbstverständlich sein müssten als
autor habe ich immer gewusst weshalb
mich nicht erzählte geschichten und
vergessene ereignisse anziehen
auf die piste gebracht hätte nein ich
habe das immer verstanden es ist nicht
so schwierig aber ich glaube dass jede
art von neurose eine gewisse art von
energie produziert du hast eine
neurotische fixierung ok nutze sie wenn
ich von solchen geschichten angezogen
bin erzähle sie sage nicht wo das ist
mein problem ich müsste davon geheilt
werden überhaupt nicht
das andere ist wenn sie über rilke
sprechen und sagen du musst dein leben
ändern
diese aussage hat mich immer getroffen
als wäre es mühelos auf alle fälle
glaube ich nicht dass das einfach so
geht
ich glaube nicht dass menschen einfach
entscheiden
ich verändere mein leben ich muss mein
leben verändern das leben der menschen
wird durch ereignisse veränderte sie
nicht vorhersehen können und nicht
unbedingt verstehen wenn sie geschehen
vielleicht bringen sie im weiteren
verlauf ihres lebens darum zu verstehen
und es gelingt nicht aber sie wissen das
hat mich verändert das hat mich anders
zurückgelassen und dann ringen sie darum
versuchen zu verstehen was geschehen ist
solche veränderungen sind oft nicht
persönlich nicht zwischen ihnen und
einer anderen person
sie können gesellschaftlich seien
geteilt es kann eine veränderung seien
die unzählige andere menschen ebenfalls
betrifft vielleicht auf sehr ähnliche
art vielleicht auf eine andere art das
free speech movement in berkeley hat
mich gewiss verändert so wie es viele
menschen verändert hat ich weiß aus
gesprächen die ich im lauf der jahre
geführt habe dass sich manche gleich
verändert haben wie ich andere ganz
anders und manche waren überhaupt nicht
hoffen aber veränderungen geschehen wenn
man sie am wenigsten erwartet
ich habe den eindruck dass sie seine
gabe haben eine permanente gab es sich
überraschen zu lassen selbst von einem
song eben wie like a rolling stone den
sie hunderttausende informale gehört
haben diese diese latente haltung der
bereitschaft ihr leben zu ändern über
einen einfluss etwas was kommt ja das
hoffe ich sicher schon jetzt bringt das
ein bisschen in die in die zukunft oder
wenn wir noch einmal vielleicht den
kulturpessimisten george steiner bemühen
würden zu sagen also etwas ist am ende
und zum beispiel rock'n'roll war ja
schon einmal in den 60er jahren am ende
etwas noch einmal am ende nach dem
beatles und ihnen kommen diese dinge
immer wieder und immer wieder scheint
sie für eine neue generation auch noch
einmal frisch oder neu und die wirklich
neuen dingen also wenn sie jetzt sagen
sie sind auch wie ein seismograph oder
wie eine antenne sie haben dermaßen viel
wissen dass sie dinge antizipieren
können wenn sie in die zukunft schauen
oder wenn sie über bier und sie
schreiben haben sie das gefühl das ist
jetzt da wo die zeitgenossenschaft sich
bricht oder was in eine zukunft hinein
läuft
nein nein ich habe keine macht oder gar
nicht einmal ein interesse oder den
wunsch die zukunft vorherzusagen
ich weiß wenn ich es versuchen würde
läge ich genauso falsch wie alle anderen
auch jegliche vorhersage für die zukunft
ist nichts anderes als ein weiterspinnen
die gegenwart
man liest nie eine zukunftsprognose die
besagt dass wir in 100 jahren in eine
totale barbara absinken werden und die
fähigkeit der straße verloren haben das
ist eine ziemlich heftige
zukunftsprognose nicht wahr
aber sie steht in krassem widerspruch zu
unserer heutigen situation
das ist nicht die art und weise wie
menschen die zukunft vorhersagen in
wirklichkeit sagen alte leute wenn sie
heute 2016 die zukunft vorhersagen das
gleiche dass sie bereits 1956 gesagt
haben wir werden fliegende autos haben
das ist ziemlich das was die leute sagen
wenn sie heute die zukunft
prognostizieren
es ist irgendwie dumm es gibt eine menge
von dingen in der heutigen kultur in der
musik und in anderen bereichen die an
mir vorbeigegangen sind
die mich nicht bewegen nicht berühren
ich vergeude meine zeit nicht mit dem
versuch den sinn von dingen zu suchen
die mich nicht interessieren
und es gibt gewisse dinge die bei uns
gemacht hat und gewisse formen wie sie
sich selber darstellt mehr als ihre
musik die mich interessieren
aber ich mag mich nicht darauf festlegen
ich höre lieber lady gaga zu diese
wunderbare aufnahmen die sie gemacht hat
bad romance ist eine wirkliche darauf
nahmen in der letzten minute dieses
kampfes in alle richtungen dieser alles
auf einmal aufnahme in der letzten
minute wird es sogar noch chaotisch ab
das momentum spitzt sich zu und man
glaubt dass es jede sekunde auseinander
bricht
man glaubt einfach nicht dass das
zusammenhält und sie beginnt in
sinnlosen 7 zu singen einschließlich da
da da das kommt da rein alles löst sich
auf und dann endet es das ist die art
von transzendenz die wir ohne job
steiners worten zu sprechen nicht mehr
erleben auf die ich immer hoffe was
passiert was geht hier vor
woraus ist all das gemacht diese fragen
kommen hoch also es werden sie sagen
wenn steiner noch einmal dein letztes
mal sagen würde wir haben die fähigkeit
verloren heute einen shakespeare einen
dante zu erkennen in unserer gegenwart
dann würden sie sagen in diesem moment
drin wie es jetzt mit lady gaga
beschrieben haben und sagen das ist so
eine art von moment wo sie tante der
zeitgenossenschaft erlebt haben wissen
sie manchmal finden leute wenn sie älter
werden die welt um sich herum zutiefst
irritierend mehr noch in bezug auf die
eigene existenz ergeben die dinge keinen
sinn mehr
deshalb muss alles wertvolle verloren
sein
ich glaube nicht dass die menschen im
siebzehnten jahrhundert ein besuch von
shakespeares theaterstücken die äußerst
populär waren
wo der zuschauer raum gefüllt war mit
einfachen menschen die kreischten nur
mit den füßen stampfen und auf eine
völlig populistische art reagierten
ich bin überzeugt dass die leute damals
sagten er ist großartig er ist ein genie
wenn sie dieses wort damals überhaupt
benutzt er ist ein geschenk gottes ohr
shakespeare und wenn wir gesagt hätten
glauben sie dass die menschen in 400
jahren noch über william shakespeare
sprechen werden
ich weiß nicht wer konnte dass
voraussagen william shakespeare war bis
ins neunzehnte jahrhundert als er
wiederentdeckt wurde ziemlich aus der
geschichte verschwunden
es gibt keine transzendenz die sofort
erkannt wird und nie verschwindet die
transzendenz das genie von jesus
christus ist im wesentlichen ein
literarisches konstrukt
das sehr bald nach seinem verschwinden
begangen also da beschreiben sie
natürlich auch ein bisschen ihre eigene
rolle der im beschreiben von wundern das
wunder zu packen und damit auch eine
form von trans in den tieren überhaupt
zu ermöglichen
das stimmt aber ich versuche nicht ein
autorität system und eine reihe von
dingen aufzubauen die die leute glauben
müssen
aber da gibt es vielleicht sein einen
sicherheitskordon ich habe das gefühl
dass wenn man eben über diese art der
kultur wahrnehmung wie sie leben und
spüren und schreiben machen sind sie ein
vermittler nicht in einem dogmatischen
zimmer in einem elitären sind sondern
sie beschreiben für mich was es bedeutet
ein fan zu sein
ja ich schreibe als fan sicher ich
schreibe über dinge die mich bewegen
ich schreibe aus enthusiasmus es könnte
negative enthusiasmus sein ärger und
missbilligung gleichermaßen die liebe
und entzücken klar vor ein paar jahren
las ich einen artikel von jemandem der
eine kulturelle auseinandersetzung über
eine bestimmte sache beschrieb bei der
es zwei unterschiedliche standpunkte gab
und er sagte
das hat so viel hitze erzeugt die leute
schlagen sich auf die eine oder die
andere seite
es scheint als ob die wirklichen themen
verdunkelt worden
vielleicht würde dieser diskussion die
meinung von jemandem dem es egal ist gut
tun
ich dachte nur das ist die essenz einer
schlechten kritik das ist die essenz vom
missbrauch von kritik indem man sich
einer sache verschreibt über der mann
steht wo man sich überlegen fühlt
in den usa gab es einen filmkritiker der
sehr lange im geschäft war johns heim
er hatte immer das gefühl wenn er über
filme schrieb dass es ihm sogar peinlich
wäre beim kinobesuch gesehen zu werden
wäre er nicht von einer
prestigeträchtigen publikation dafür
bezahlt genau das zu tun
das ist was seine kritiken immer
kommuniziert für mich ist solche kritik
kaum die rede wert geschweige denn
lesenswert wenn jemand ohne leidenschaft
schreibt über was auch immer ohne sich
berührt zu fühlen
ohne zu spüren dass wenn sie es schaffen
die geschichte zu erzählen sie von ihr
erfüllt werden und dass wenn sie
scheitern sie nicht nur an sich selber
gescheitert sind dass sie die geschichte
vermasseln
die sie uns so viele andere menschen
hätte bewegen können wenn diese art von
einem notar weshalb sich planen
natürlich ist die ist pop und rock bis
hin zu punk auch eine eine kommerzielle
kultur auch malcolm mclaren hat die sex
pistols erfunden sie um seine t-shirts
zu verkaufen es ist immer auch eine art
von von massenprodukte die hergestellt
werden wie fußball ja auch eine art von
von massen fenton generiert und eine
zugehörigkeit generiert und es fällt sie
nicht zunehmend schwerer in der
kommerzialisierung in der kälte der
industrie der popindustrie und popkultur
eine art von dieser leidenschaft
überhaupt noch zu spüren weil sie merken
nach welchen strickmustern emotionen
gemacht werden produziert werden nun
mich stört die tatsache nicht dass
popmusik rock'n'roll punk wie immer sie
es nennen wollen immer ein
kapitalistisches unterfangen
es waren stets zahlreiche motive
dahinter und für viele leute war über
eine lange zeitspanne geld machen reich
werden das wichtigste motiv sogar das
beherrschende motiv
interessant ist jedoch was auch immer
die motivation ist es bringt leute dazu
dinge zu tun die sie sonst nicht tun
würden
es bringt sie dazu stimmen zu entdecken
formen musikalischer kommunikation die
sonst nie entwickelt worden wären die es
nie gegeben hätte oder die nicht
entdeckt worden wären
es bringt menschen dazu ihre tiefsten
gefühle auszudrücken auf eine weise die
entweder absolut offen oder komplett
verschlüsselt ist auf eine art die auf
menschen verführerisch verwirrend
faszinierend wirkt so wie sie selber
oder auch ganz anders
dieses motiv stört mich also überhaupt
nicht ich sehe die grenzen einfach nicht
dort wo sie von so vielen leuten
wahrgenommen werden
nehmen sie ein stück wie shake it off
von taylor swift eine unglaubliche
aufnahme ein offensichtlich erhöht schon
nach zehn sekunden realisiert man was
für ein hitlers ist wenn sie es einige
male gehört haben hören sie nur noch den
ablauf alles was sie hören ist ein
einschub hier und ein einschub dort
genau wie wenn jemand ein puzzle-spiel
zusammensitzt bei dem er weiß ich sage
er weil ich von den produzenten sprechen
die männlich sind
wenn sie ein puzzle zusammensetzen dass
sie schon oft gemacht haben wissen sie
genau wo die stücke hingehören
ja ich finde es befremdend
aber das ist nicht alles was drinsteckt
es gibt dieses und es gibt jene zu hören
und zu realisieren wie berechnet und
seelenlos es ist verhindert nicht zu
hören wie spontan und seelenvoll etwas
anderes
ein sofa ich möchte nochmals auf dieses
seelen hafte und auf diesen befreiungs
moment und auch hat einen kollektiven
moment zurück kommen sie haben jetzt ein
zwei mal die frisbee und bewegung
erwähnt wir haben einen kleinen
ausschnitt aus berkley aus den 60er
jahren
wir können weiter reden aber einfach
dass wir uns das noch einmal vor augen
führen wie das war das ist ihre ihre
zeit in diesem herbst regnete es vielen
berkley
man hat nicht unbedingt das gefühl dass
hier sehr viel befreiter menschen eine
etwas etwas neues kennen ist eine sehr
ernste sehr strukturiert also jetzt hier
nicht sehr strukturiert aber eine sehr
ernste geschichte da waren sie so alt
wie tristan tzara im cabaret voltaire ja
ich war 19
ich weiß nicht ich sehe menschen die nie
zuvor aufgestanden sind und vor anderen
leuten gesprochen haben ich sehe
menschen die ihre fähigkeit entdecken
sich auch um andere zu kümmern als
bisher
ich sehe menschen die herumgehen und
transparente tragen die sich ein jahr
zuvor nicht hätten vorstellen können je
so etwas zu tun und ich sehe menschen in
einer situation die zuweilen äußerst
beängstigend war
man hatte keine ahnung was die eigenen
handlungen oder die aktionen anderer
leute auslösen würden
und ich sehe etwas das so aussieht als
wäre es vor langer zeit geschehen
aufgrund der art wie sich die leute
kleideten und je länger ihre haare
solche dinge wenn ich dieses
filmmaterial anschaut scheint mir das
ganze in der tat viel weiter weg zu sein
als in meinem gedächtnis über jene zeit
meine erinnerungen sind frischer als
dieses filmmaterial und das ist der 1964
und hatten sie dann 1968 eine art von
déjà vu haben sie das gefühl gehabt es
passiert noch einmal hier in paris in
berlin in der schweiz auch noch einmal
etwas was sie schon erlebt hatten vier
jahre früher
ja 1968 in den usa unterschied sich sehr
stark von 1968 in europa oder japan
mexiko wo es enorme manchmal
katastrophale demonstrationen und
veranstaltungen gab
wir sprechen von paris vom prager
frühling vom massaker an hunderten von
studenten in mexico city vor den
olympischen spielen die in jenem jahr
dort stattfanden
wir sprechen von unruhen in
westdeutschland von verschiedensten
demonstrationen in england und auch in
den usa aber in den usa war es anders
wir hatten einen
präsidentschaftswahlkampf martin luther
king wurde ermordet
robert kennedy wurde ermordet wir
schauen hier auf zeiten des absoluten
horrors zurück in diesem sinn war es
anders 1968 war nicht was für großartige
dinge die sich aus dem ereignis
entwickelt haben dessen teilt so sei
nicht das glück hatte es war mein gott
wer wird als nächster umgebracht also
die öffnung von 64 dieses möglich sein
ist schon wieder hinein geht wieder zu
und wenn wir jetzt heute auch ohne dass
wir jetzt in die zukunft schauen möchten
aber heute nach amerika schauen und
merken dass zwei
präsidentschaftskandidaten im rennen
sind die ihrer generation sind mehr oder
weniger wir haben donald trump und
werden
hillary clinton also jetzt kommt diese
generation an die macht was bedeutet das
ich weiß nicht was das bedeutet
irgendwie ist es verrückt meine
generation war schon vorher an der macht
will clinton gehört zu dieser generation
george hw bush gehört zu dieser
generation
ich weiß nicht ich finde es ziemlich
skurril
die idee dass die leute sagen hillary
clinton solle bernie sanders euro joe
biden als ihren kandidaten für die vize
präsidentschaft wählen
jemand der sogar älter ist viel älter
dass donald trump einen weiteren
70-jährigen bestimmen sollte es ist als
auf die generationen dahinter
verschwunden wären
ich weiß nicht mich beschäftigt weniger
das alter der kandidaten als die reife
der einen und die unreife des anderen
ich meine
im wesentlichen haben sie mit hillary
clinton eine 60 jährige kandidatin und
einen achtjährigen kandidaten mit donald
trump frage des revivals dies immer
wieder abtauchen das wiederauftauchen
ein bisschen ist rock'n'roll wie das
monster von loch ness hat man den
eindruck
und es gibt diesen wunderbaren songs von
neil young von 1979 rock nevada ist eine
eine eine strophe wie lesen sie diese
strophe für uns wir erklären sie uns
diese strophe ich erinnere mich als ich
diesen song zum ersten mal hörte out of
the blue ant ins oder plug-ins oder
black auto zu blut das ist die
geschichte von johnny rotten der könig
ist weg aber er ist nicht vergessen
es war in einem musikclub in san
francisco bevor der sonne auf platte
herausgebracht wurde
und er trat solo auf und hey hey my my
rock n' roll wird niemals sterben
die ironie ist einfach überwältigend
diese worte sind darin getränkt wie naiv
müssen sie seien zu denken das rock'n
roll niemals sterben wird
es schien als wolle er das sagen das ist
was er als erstes sagt und dann sagt er
aber nein er wird nicht sterben ich
werde es nicht zulassen ich will das
nicht aber ich weiß wie dumm das ist
alles stirbt alles verschwindet alles
verändert sich
nein nein das ist das entscheidende
ich glaube das ist ein sehr schönes
schlusswort gewesen
grell markus vielen herzlichen dank für
das gespräch thank you
ich danke ihnen das war wie ein
vergnügen nächste woche unterhält sich
meine kollegin barbara bleisch mit dem
vielfach ausgezeichneten dirigenten und
pianisten daniel barenboim ein gespräch
das sie nicht verpassen sollten
und wir wir bleiben in den usa und
zeigen ihnen gleich einen film über die
dokumentarfotografie thora sie allein
die mitunter die familie von greil
marcus fotografiert und in den 20er
jahren
[Musik]